Is there a blood test to show that I'm getting better? How can I tell?
Maybe, maybe not. So there's no perfect way to know
whether our cancer is shrinking or not even in, you know, with gold standard testing that is like
PET scans and MRIs or CT scans. I've always said that it's good to
you know, compare apples to apples. We need that. Okay, if the size of your breast
tumor was determined by an MRI, how am I going to know if it's shrinking unless I do
another MRI, preferably from the same place, preferably read by the same
radiologist. Now I don't know, none of those things are, you know, a given, but you're
trying to be as close to comparison from size by using the same type of scans.
So if you did breast ultrasound, it'd be better to go to the same ultrasound
facility and get the ultrasound read that way that you're going to have close to
the best comparison. Now what if you don't have a tumor that can be measured with a scan
an ultrasound an MRI or CT scan? A PET scan is another way to look at things, but of
course all these things that we're talking about except ultrasounds are invasive.
You're getting radiation when you're doing, you know, CT scans, you're getting
gadolinium usually because you have to do a contrast eye when you're doing an MRI.
So that's not always our first choice. That's not even the question. The question is there
a blood test? So is there a blood test to know how I'm doing? Well, if your cancer is one
that shows tumor markers, that is the benefit of running tumor marker tests. So if you have
a cancer that tends to show tumor markers, then if you got a baseline and your tumor marker
is going down, that's a clue. So I don't think any of these tests that I'm talking about
are going to be perfect. Maybe just because my tumor markers are going down does not mean
that, you know, my cancer is getting better. There's other things that you look at too.
But that is one indication that your tumor is getting better. If your tumor marker is going
up, does that mean your cancer is getting worse? Maybe, maybe not. It's a clue that gives
us, you know, reason to pause and reason to think and you compare it with other things.
So as far as a blood test goes, those tumor markers are one thing that may be valuable. There's
other things on the blood test that can give us clues. So if, you know, that's why I want
you guys to be getting a complete comprehensive metabolic panel on a regular basis and a CBC,
a complete blood count with differential on a regular basis. So if my complete blood count
has been normal and you're looking at these things over time, my complete blood count has
been normal over time. But now I'm starting to develop an anemia. Does that, what does that
mean? That could be an indication that your cancer is progressing because as our cancer
progresses, one of the things that is common, it's not always present, but it's common is for
an anemia to be present because cancer can be gobbled up iron because of the high metabolic
rate of the cancer. The complete metabolic, comprehensive metabolic panel, we can be looking
at two liver markers. We could be looking at alkaline phosphatase. We could be looking
at calcium markers. So there's things that can give us clues, but there's not going to
be one thing that it's going to say, oh my gosh, your cancer is absolutely getting worse.
We know we on a shadow of a doubt because of this one test. So you use blood work to give
us clues to maybe dig a little deeper, plus you use subjective findings as well. Am I feeling
better or am I feeling worse? So you put all these pieces of the puzzle together to come
up with a diagnosis whether the progression of the cancer whether it's getting better or
it's getting worse.